wie geht's weiter mit der groko und mit
angela merkel reden drüber mit einem
mann dessen biografie wirklich
erstaunliche parallelen zur kanzlerin
hat er kommt aus ostdeutschland und er
hat seinen zenit schon vor jahren
überschritten olaf schubert zusammen und
herren
schön dass du da bist
angela merkel hört auf hat cdu-chefin
was hast du empfunden als du das
erfahren dass teile deine emotionen mit
uns
ich war gespalten
denn ich muss sagen auf der einen seite
habe ich mich wirklich gefreut für sie
weil sie dann einfach mehr zeit hat auf
der anderen seite war ich in meinen
gedanken natürlich ganz nahe bei ihrem
mann einen muss es immer tragen
aber dass sie geht das also das geht mir
schon also es geht mir nahe also das
jetzt geht das geht mir schon ans herz
und das ist komisch bis dahin gehen sie
mal auf den sack also das glaubst du sie
ist freiwillig gegangen
ja also freiwillig nach intensiver
aufforderung ganz klar aber was ist wenn
der erfolg ausbleibt also wenn die hände
der parteifreunde die eben noch auf die
schulter geklopft haben sich dann so
langsam um die gurgel legen dank dann
muss man reagieren aber ich denke
zumindest ist es nur eine finte also so
wie ich sie kenne da war dass er die
wollte einfach mal so die großen maler
aus der partei aus der reserve locken
und jetzt jetzt werden die irgendwo in
brandenburg im cdu gulag interniert und
merkel regiert weiter bis selbst die
junge union verrottet ist naja was wird
zu sagen in der rückschau ein paar
jahren was wird man sagen was bleibt von
der ära merkel einige ist also es
bleiben drei schränke voller hosenanzüge
und es war natürlich eine ära ganz klar
also in meiner als erster kanzler wurde
damals da gab es noch nicht mal ein
iphone 2005 ja ja also auf dem ersten
foto wenn man wo sie was sie als
kanzlerin sagt wenn man ganz genau
hinschaut das sieht man im hintergrund
im hintergrund und da sieht man dass
diese mammut durch berlin stapft also
das ist ganz andere epoche und 13 jahre
13 jahre ich meine fast wird heute noch
über den hitler geredet bei dem wir uns
und man muss ja auch mal muss auch mal
anerkennen sagen am ende von merkels
regierung seit ist deutschland ja dann
doch insgesamt in einem besseren zustand
als damals 45 wirklich auch sagen
deutlich besser deutlich mehr sag ich ja
also ich denke die die lücke die frau
merkel hinterlässt die muss man erst mal
finden oder oder anders gesagt
die wird ja auch ganz schnell gestopft
so wird frau kann baureihen dass sie
sagt quasi ein anmerke clown
das ist natürlich jetzt schwer wieder
eine frau aber aus dem saarland saarland
steht ja noch unter ostdeutschland also
da mal gucken wie es schwierig merkel
will spätestens ab 2021 keine
politischen ämter mehr wie stellst du
ihre zukunft vor
ich habe bei den fußballern ist ja immer
so dass die dann so durch die kleineren
klubs dinge so wird es auch machen da
sie irgendwie normal bei der spd ein
hort als vorsitzender jahr so
spd-vorsitzende es macht sinn nebenbei
von zuhause ich meine rostocker markt
ein paar monate die es noch gibt
ja und dann wird sie natürlich
hoffentlich die zeit nutzen sie hat er
viele kontakte das ist ja etwas gutes
wenn man ganz oben so lange dabei ist du
kennst du kennst die ganz großen du
kennst ja horst lichter sie hat kontakt
zur nationalmannschaft
vielleicht fängt sie nochmal an beim dfb
so als einlauf mädchen
fusionieren
ich wünsche mir für sie natürlich in
erster linie sicherheit das ist das
wichtigste
denn die hfg angedroht jahren wieder an
die macht kommen
sie haben diese vor gericht und so und
also deshalb jetzt von mir hier auch mal
ein ganz klares statement falls es dazu
kommt frau merkel sie können sie bei mir
jederzeit verstecken also ich meine
jetzt nicht in der wohnung geklaut
frauen dem altern macht ja auch arbeit
aber hin zum haus haben sie uns in
sachen umweltschutz
[Applaus]
[Musik]